What does the word driver mean in our food lists?
A driver in our
In our vernacular. I mean something that it could be fueling the cancer
So if I said a driver was you know if estrogen is a driver that could be
Quoting-quote fueling a cancer was not particularly fueling a cancer in the case of estrogens blocking the estrogen beta receptors
which is an apoptonic receptor which is
Blocking a poptosis to a cancer
But in a food if there is a driver, then dairy could be feeding the cancer by being a fuel source for the cancer or vice in the case of dairy
It would be basically
Stimulating through growth hormones through up regulating the mTOR pathway
You know glucose is a driver for the cancer because it's a direct fuel source because glucose
Brakes dealt through glycolysis to end point to proveic acid and converts to lactic acid especially if people have
HIF1 AG defects
So you end up with excess lactic acid and lactic acid is a direct fuel source for cancer
So driver means what could be basically fueling or feeding the cancer?